So Cameron, why are we here?
>> I'm just checking out this soccer, I mean football scores.
>> And how does that relate to JavaScript?
>> You'll see.
Okay. So if I ask you whether or
not the US won any of these games, how you would respond?
Let's start with this first one against Ghana.
Did we win?
>> True.
>> Correct.
Okay.
What about this one, against Belgium?
>> Hm.
False.
>> Also correct.
All right. One last one.
What about that one, against Argentina?
>> Hm.
We didn't even play them.
>> correct.
And JavaScript gives us a way of expressing this, as Undefined.
>> Okay.
I see what you're getting at.
True and False isn't as cut and dry as our football chart.
JavaScript has a set of values that can evaluate to true or
false, but many not equal true or false.
Because of this, we call these values truthy and falsy.
Under truthy, we've got true, non-zero numbers,
strings with a length of at least one, objects, arrays, and functions.
And under falsy, we've got false, zero,
empty strings, undefined, null and Not a Number.
>> Undefined means that the variable doesn't exist and
the interpreter doesn't know what you're referring to.
Null means that the variable exist, but has well no value.
It's usually used as a placeholder.
And Not a Number is not a number or a result that isn't a number.
>> There's a link in the instructor's notes comparing Truthy and
Falsy values in Python and JavaScript.
Let's take a quiz to make sure you got them all.